foreign
you are looking at live images from our
Fox Flight Team over Eagle Pass Texas
part of the Del Rio sector where in the
last 24 hours there were
1284 apprehensions bring in the fiscal
year just 29 days in at almost 39
000 yet migrants continue to stream into
the U.S at an alarming rate let's bring
in the spokesperson for the Texas
Department of Public Safety and South
Texas region Lieutenant Chris Oliveira's
LT thanks for being here you and I has
spent a lot of time covering this crisis
and I am just struck by the fact that as
we are just 29 days into this fiscal
year it doesn't seem that things are
slowing down by any stretch of the
imagination
and it's not Griff it's not so one thing
I could tell you for a fact is
especially when we talk about human
smuggling we've continued to see an
increase in human smuggling events
throughout the southern borders more
specifically the Eagle Pass Del Rio area
and we continue to see drivers uh from
larger metropolitan areas Houston Dallas
San Antonio even out of state that are
making this drive uh to the border to
become human Smugglers because it
continues to be advertised uh through
social media platforms and criminal
smuggling organizations continue to
exploit that and they continue to
recruit drivers so they can expand their
criminal Enterprise throughout the
United States in terms of human
smuggling we know it's a multi-billion
dollar trade criminal organizations are
making more money on human smugging than
they are on drugs and we continue to see
different trends of human smuggling that
we're seeing throughout the Border as
well LT I think one of the most uh
insightful aspects of this increase in
smuggling are the amazing videos that
you yourself in Lupe and your team put
out of the daily smuggling uh 10
attempts that are thwarted you can see
here this one that you shot and released
this week in Eagle Pass area the how
many migrants came out of this dump
truck it's just stunning footage
right it is studied I mean just to see
that it's staggering especially when you
know that these are these immigrants are
being smuggled through these type of
methods whether it be in a car whether
it be in a trailer and in this case a
dump truck there was well over 100
immigrants and one thing that you don't
see on that video is when that Trooper
make that stop on that dump truck there
was many more immigrants that actually
fled from that dump truck into the brush
but we were able to rescue 84 of those
immigrants uh from that dump truck that
were crammed inside we were able to
arrest the driver and now he's facing 84
counts of human smuggling but again
Griffith what's important and you just
you brought up a good point is really
showing what's taking place along the
border aside from the humanitarian
crisis but exposing the criminal
Elements by showing these videos and
showing what these human Smothers are
doing by exploiting these immigrants and
putting them in danger as well but also
when when you have when you have
inexperience uh especially in this case
for the commercial vehicle a driver in
this case that driver did not have the
proper license to operate a commercial
vehicle so you're driving an 80 000
pound vehicle on a roadway it's not on
only endanger the lives of those
migrants but also the motor Republic and
that's why through operation Lone Star
we've been able to enhance board
operations we've been able to enhance
commercial vehicle safety inspections
along the border by stopping some of
these trucks to make sure they are in
compliance with federal and state
regulations but also to focus on those
criminal smoking organizations
in these Smugglers they're just
completely ruthless disregard for the
safety and well-being of the migrants
you know LT I want to mention as uh Nate
foy's point out in his great reporting
today uh Chief Ortiz the border patrol
tweeted out a seven-day results of
apprehensions and whatnot among them the
criminal migrants uh some seven sexual
offenders one murderer three migrants
criminals with guns and it's been an
increase of the dangerous not everyone
is from the Central American country
seeking a peaceful Asylum it's a point
that is constantly made and I want to
ask you are you at all surprised or even
frustrated that we're hearing so much
about crime this election cycle in
cities like Philadelphia in New York the
shootings people being pushed on subway
but yet they don't make the connection
with the criminal aspect coming across
our border it's left out of the
conversation
right that's a great Point Griff but I
mean that's that's a that's important
that's going to be important especially
going into November because the Border
crisis impacts not just those border
communities but the entire country when
we talk about crime and not just not
just those criminal immigrants that are
coming across our borders which you
haven't you have seen many times when
you've been out there on those private
ranches the type of people that we
encounter on a daily basis also those
that are being reported by U.S border
Patrol but that is that is a very
important issue to focus on that
criminal element and the crime has taken
place along the border with some of
these individuals that are coming across
you report it I believe it was several
weeks ago we came across a an individual
on a private Ranch from Honduras who was
wanted for murder you know that's just
one individual that we came across so
how many more have gotten by especially
when you take into account the number of
dataways combined for fiscal year 21 and
22 almost 1 million known godaways that
should be a serious issue that that
Americans need to focus on because it's
a threat not only to those border
communities but a threat to our to our
national security as well because again
even with the 98 terrorists that have
been apprehended well so you know that
one more one terrorist uh that is more
than enough to get across our border
when you see close to 100 that is a
serious threat to National Security
fighting and sobering thoughts there
Texas exactly DPS Lieutenant Chris
olivarez Lieutenant thank you for your
time hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else